hello to
everybody
hope you are all doing fabulous
um you are on ask doc live my name is
rebecca kozak i will be your host for
the next two hours and if you are on
live with us today we do have the chat
option
turned on
so in your zoom menu you can click chat
and it will show all the valuable
information that will or is being shared
with in the meeting throughout the
meeting um by our co-host jonty
mccollier nassema omar and ruth ellen
sanchez
now i do want to remind you if your
honor with us live there is no
solicitation or advertising within this
chat
our co-hosts are beautiful people and
they're here to maintain the integrity
of the show so if we do see any type of
solicitation
you will be removed from
from our live presentation
now the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation
food supplies around the world are empty
and void of what the body needs not just
to survive but actually thrive
and in this program we will be sharing
nutritional options that are available
to fill those gaps through
supplementation in a form that the body
can actually utilize and absorb
now the fda does require us to let you
know that our products are not meant to
treat prevent diagnose or cure any
disease
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician but
our good doctor dr joel wallock has been
instrumental in suing this fine fda with
a vic with
nine victories and these victories have
led to the addition of vital nutrients
into foods and allowing the distribution
of information proven by science to be
factual in the essential need of
supplementation against disease
we also bring to you the news that the
genetic theory has been proven incorrect
through the science of epigenetics which
is the study of how your own behaviors
and the things in your environment can
cause changes that affect the way that
your genes work
now with empty genetics you are an
empowered individual
and have more control over your health
journey than you think
some communities don't want you to think
that you have any power and that you
have to rely on them but you have it
within you and the information that we
share with you on this program helps to
support your ability
to be empowered
any testimonials on this program are
totally
voluntary not scheduled
and they are using products that have
been recommended by our dr joel wallet
now to guide us we are so honored to
have one of the founding fathers of
epigenetics here to share the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health dr joel wallach welcome dr
wallach
well good morning rebecca and team thank
you so much for the
for the presents and all the great
things you do and of course um
when it comes to
defeating the
the
misinformation when it came to genetics
it didn't just you know come out of a
dream
uh actually it was a 25 million dollar
grant it was my second uh post-doctoral
fellowship
um
25 million dollars
and um
i was able to do
20 000 autopsies 17 thousand some change
over 454 species of zoo animals and
three thousand humans and the purpose of
the study
was to find a canary in the mind so to
speak in in the zoos in the big cities
around the world
because during those days
uh
uh 1967
to 1977 a 10-year study
um
it was
everything had to do with pollution
and of course the canary in the mine
everybody who knows about coal mining i
knew that the other people who all over
the world who did coal mining would take
a little cage with a canary in it down
in the mine with them if gases were to
escape into the mine
uh that were bad the canaries would drop
off the perch and die and they knew to
get out so they didn't do the same thing
and so the whole idea was to find
several species or one species of zoo
animals
from all over the world in the big city
zoos
it was sensitive to the same pollutants
that humans were and if they began to
get sick or die we knew to evacuate the
cities to save the people
so there's a whole purpose of the thing
and but what i got as a side benefit
which turned out to be the greater
benefit
was that there are no transmitted
diseases all the diseases said to be
genetic are really just simple
nutritional deficiency diseases
and of course
um
that got me fired from the irkee's
primate center in emory university in
atlanta georgia i was a pathologist for
nasa back then
and i ran into the first case of cystic
fibrosis supposed to be the classic
example of a genetic disease in humans i
found the first case in monkeys
and um
got it um
agreed upon that it was sizzicabros
tonight now it didn't tell them that the
slides were from a monkey i just said i
think
these slides illustrate um cystic
fibrosis you know from an autopsy that i
did
what do you think
and they all the medical school i think
i sent it to five medical schools they
all sent back the letters a classic
example of physical process that i told
him was a it was a monkey not a human
and at the very least we had a
a um
laboratory animal okay that we could
study cystic fibrosis oh they
they they were so excited that we had a
non-human case of cystic fibrosis we
could study it and find out how to treat
it well it turns out that there was a
couple of environmentalists uh who
didn't like the monkeys being in cages
and they're picking their hair because
they had nothing else to do so they took
away their monkey pellets all the
vitamins and minerals in it gave them
bananas and carrots and apples and beans
and things like that and of course they
were nutritionally deficient and they
got acidic roasted now there are 24
other baby monkeys in the colonies i got
permission to do before they fired me i
got permission to
do biopsies in the other 24 monkeys sure
enough they all had cystic fibrosis that
freaked everybody out and that's when
they fired me
and i went that's when i went back to
school and became an atrocitic physician
okay
well that information that i published
um uh was five thousand pages okay
and it turned out to be a great book
it's called disease of exotic animals uh
w saunders was the classic example of a
publishing company for
textbooks
and they bought the rights to that book
they called it diseases of exotic
animals they initially published 90 000
copies they sold them in 30 days at 25
each they sold them for 25. i didn't get
much of that
okay but
they sold them for 25 000 they said they
reprinted them again sold them for 25
000 each it's called diseases of exotic
animals um
and go you know go look it up on on siri
or someplace else are there any um
dr wallach's books diseases of exotic
animals available for sale and they'll
give you some that are on you know some
some doctor researcher died and the
family is trying to sell that book and
they'll sell it if they're beat up
they'll sell them for fifteen hundred or
two thousand dollars if they're in fair
condition they'll sell them for
three thousand to six thousand dollars
if they're in good condition they'll
sell them from six thousand to twelve
thousand dollars if they're still in the
box un you know wrapped and never been
open they'll sell them for twenty five
thousand thirty five thousand dollars
diseases of exotic animals very very
proud of that study
and um this that started the whole size
of epigenetics and so very very proud of
that we have the book epigenetics that's
available
and
you can go to
www.drjwollock.com
www.drjwellock.com and get the book
epigenetics there's actually a cd that
goes along with it
and you'll be amazed at what we know
about these diseases they're said to be
genetic that are not okay
and then
you have to appreciate
that
also other things happened
suddenly
my last lawsuit we were able to get the
fda to force the manufacturers of baby
formulas to put
this one nutrient into baby farmers
which they i've been trying for 25 years
medical doctors poisonous you can't put
that nutrient in there
and they'll kill the babies and so they
didn't do it for 25 years so finally
but we got the fda to force the
manufacturers of baby formulas like
infamil and similac to put this mineral
in there
and sure enough
um within a year
suddenly now there's all these front
page newspaper stories we don't know why
but sudden death syndrome has
disappeared
okay we don't know why but cystic
fibrosis has disappeared we don't know
why but musculus disappeared well cystic
fibrosis is gone
um
sediment death syndrome disappeared
and we had muscular dystrophy we gave a
bunch of charts from kids have been
diagnosed at birth with muscular speed
by biopsy classic examples
and then
you know at age 12 15 20 they were on
our program
and um their history went away so we
gave those charts to jerry lewis and and
the uh telethon and they fired jerry
lewis because he wanted to make it
available that information available to
everybody and the telethon and the
muscular history association fired jerry
lewis now he had raised two billion
dollars for them but they fired him
because they knew if he went around
saying well it's just a simple nutrition
deficiency take these nutrients you
won't have to worry about it anymore in
your family because it's not genetic
that uh suddenly now the
the um
uh
the telethon and the messages
association would be not an entity well
that's what happened because they they
made a big deal out of it and they fired
jerry lewis
um saying that you know he's out of his
mind and all that kind of stuff
and so um it's one of those things where
science marches ahead
as quickly as the truth is available
okay i'll say it that way
and
it's one of those things where
it comes down to everything from
physical stuff like muscular dystrophy
to biochemical stuff
like
emotions depression
and of course right now we have a lot of
depression going on
because you know people can't gather
uh churches are restricting how many
people can show up they have to be like
10 seats between each person mask on
and since you know it's not like church
anymore it's not like temple anymore
okay and so it's one of those things
where
people are having to adjust and they
don't like it
um we actually have a two cd set
which is available and finally we got
them
made they're actually
the sound track off of two zooms that i
did in texas
the two of our great distributors
um and these zooms go into
um what what the pandemic was doing to
churches
and church families
and so the
these two soundtracks off of these two
zooms
are
put them into one package it's a
two cd set called health crisis in the
church the cd number one cd number two
is health crisis in the church and
america and it'll blow your mind you
know what we knew
back then uh almost two years ago now
and finally we got it all done and
they're available we're shipping them
like crazy people have been wanting to
let us know when you get them kind of
thing
and so uh this includes physical disease
as well as emotional disease because
human beings
are a tribal animal we're you know we're
a herd animal we
like to be with other human beings in
our work our play and our family
activities uh whether we're cooking or
we're eating we don't like to be
isolated as one person
and so it's not part of our nature
and so
this information will really really help
you understand what's going on and lead
you in the right direction again health
crisis and the church
and health crisis in the church in
america both those cds are in one set
uh
entitled health crisis in the church you
go to
www.drjwalik.com and get them okay then
i do want to flash some numbers at you
before we get into the details of
depression
and
these are late night last night figures
okay
not much has been
put online yet this morning early but
last night figures in the world okay
this is the world
there is 367 million
871 286 infections from the covet
dead in the world is five million six
hundred and fifty nine thousand two
hundred eighty
all right
and new cases
this morning so far
okay three million two hundred eighty
five four 455 these are the new cases in
the world
russia you know they're in all this
controversy right now
uh last night they had 11 million 404
617 infections
hundred 328
seventy dead
and this morning eighty eight thousand
eight hundred and sixteen new infections
france they'll freak you out
uh france has eighteen thousand hundred
and twenty two
element back up eighteen million
18 million 122 724 infections 130 000 15
dead
168 new infections
canada
has
2 million 979
643 infections and 33 192
dead
uh as of this morning they have 25 000
new cases per day 25 000 new cases per
day
uh let's see here
oh mexico has four million seven hundred
and seventy nine thousand two hundred
ninety six
uh cases three hundred four thousand
three hundred and eight
um dead new cases they have forty eight
thousand six hundred and twenty seven
and the usa
okay these are this morning's figures
because i could get something there then
they're small because you know only half
a dozen states that reported
um let's see here usa 74 million 698
cases
902 000 now listen to this 902
um
nine hundred and
nine hundred and two thousand one
hundred ninety six
uh dead
now in three or four days it's gonna be
one million dead i'm just freaked out
over this okay new cases today
new cases today in the usa
are
351.
and so this is ongoing this is not ready
to you know give up the ghost and quit
and go away this is going on and on and
on and on now one thing you do see the
number of infections are going up but
the number of deaths are staying pretty
stable or even going down in some places
and that's because i think most of the
infections now are the omicron variant
which is very infectious but not as
deadly
okay not as deadly
as the original
variant okay
and the original variant was very deadly
as well as very infectious and so um
it is a slight change in the in how this
is playing out
but it's still very very busy um and so
uh it can keep you from going to work it
can disable your whole family and you
got to take care of three or four or six
or eight people in bed
and so forth
um
so
be aware wear your mask
use your hand sanitizer from activity
put two droppers full of our colloidal
silver under your tongue 30 minutes for
each meal 30 minutes for bedtime
i have a cart
at the front door so when i go out i use
even though i've had my colloidal silver
for the day or for the morning i'll
still do colloidal silver again i do the
hand sanitizer come back in do the hand
sanitizer and close over again
throw all the clothes and dirty clothes
do the laundry don't let anybody else do
my laundry because i've been outside
okay
and
um
it's one of those things where
you have to also protect everybody else
don't forget take your shoes off outside
and don't wear your clothes through the
house okay don't wash your clothes at
anybody else's clothes when you won't
use the washer and dryer in your house
make sure you run an empty wash with
soap and bleach and all that kind of
stuff
to clean out the washer
before you let somebody else use it
and that way you'll be ahead
now quickly
on the depression thing
the brain is a biochemical
organ in the body
it requires 90 essential nutrients
okay and so you have to pay attention
um
75 of the brain weight is cholesterol
i'll repeat that 75 of brain weight is
cholesterol so don't get on statin drugs
cholesterol is not what's causing plaque
in the arteries it's actually salad
dressings and frying and cooking oils
because plaque in the arteries not
not cholesterol that was a mistake by
the medical system and they came out
with statin drugs lower cholesterol well
that came up with depression and
alzheimer's disease and many many other
things going on in the brain
and so i want everybody to eat three
eggs twice a day well my doctor said
well just keep listening to your doctor
and you'll soon be in a nursing home
which he owns okay
and so um
do not get
statin drugs because
cholesterol is not what causes plaque
arteries if you do have plugged arteries
you also want to add the ultimate daily
plastic tablets three twice a day two
vowels a month and they will support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries your brain
your heart your kidneys if you have
if you're on dialysis you have high
pressure you need that ultimate daily
classic tablets the 90 ultimate daily
classic
let's see also you need the um healthy
brain and heart pack
one per 100 pounds of body weight
and you know you got to be proactive
here i i talked to you know one of our
distributors this morning she had a
client who had
um
let's see here oh they had
terrible terrible terrible problems
uh with um uh
the covid
okay
and so
um and but they didn't want to take any
supplements
well
you got to make sure that they're going
to take the supplements and get off all
the bad foods they can absorb no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
gluten no wheat butter ryan notes no
sugar no carbonated drinks and gluten is
one of the biggest factors
everybody eats oatmeal for breakfast
everybody eats pancakes and waffles for
breakfast save flour tortillas for lunch
they have spaghetti and
they'll have chicken noodle soup for
lunch and dinner and that kind of stuff
bread oh my gosh
beer all made from wheat wheat we that's
why we're in trouble that's why the
european countries are in trouble
because it's their diet compared to the
asian countries who live on rice and
sweet potatoes and beans and squash
instead of wheat butter in oats totally
different diets since the diet
is causing our problems
well in addition to the two health
abandoned heart packs
uh i also uh want people to have
our
de-stress capsules capital d like david
dash stress three of those twice a day
per hundred pounds body weight um they
need to
um
take our fucoid z capsules they can take
three twice a day per hundred pounds of
body weight unless they prefer the
liquid
if they weigh a hundred pounds they
could take one quart or the z radical
which is liquid form a few coins z which
is from the seaweed in one ocean
and it
supports
healthy
brain function including
for
behavior and health and
and you know prevention and reversal of
depression
depression is a biochemical
problem
okay
and it wouldn't hurt if you're a boy i
also take the um zerat test
take um
three of those twice a day it's two
miles a month if you're a girl you want
to take zero femme take three of those
twice a day and and along with your
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
soft yolks you want uh hard-boiled eggs
won't count and so between the eggs
and the cholesterol
and all these raw materials that your
body needs to make the hormones
in most cases depression is going to go
away
it's uh something that i've been dealing
with for
50 years not personally but with
patients and customers and clients and
our
various associates our wonderful
associates all over the world
it doesn't matter who you are where
you're from if you're taking the
nutrients and staying away from the bad
stuff depression goes away
it's not genetic
it's not autoimmune
it has to do with what you're eating
what you're not eating
and
what you're supplementing with and what
you're not supplementing with the
prescription drugs you're on
and so all of this is easily
fixable
and maintainable
and so
there should not be one depressed
american i want that i'm just going to
invite all the psychiatrists to join us
and become an associate with youngevity
because if everybody listens to me
psychiatrists won't have much to do
you know in the old days grandma was a
psychiatrist and um grandma
would you know make you some nice
bean soup or some squash for dinner or
something like that
excuse me if you have
all these emotional problems she'd sit
there and talk with you for a few
minutes
and grandma was the everything for
everybody she was a surgeon she was
um
she was a diagnostician
she was the person who would deal with
your depression
she would coach you
she'd cook and teach everybody else how
to cook and so forth so it's one of
those things where it's a
miracle
and of course we had to have all these
grandmothers
which is
what's what's good for us
i'm hoping as a grandmother i can pass
along a lot of those things that
grandmothers in the past
passed on to their grandchildren and
children and i just wanted to really
point out you know depression can be
situational it could be chemical
imbalances it could be hormonal
imbalances it can be caused by
pharmaceuticals because by all three
at the same time three
absolutely and when we support our
bodies
so that our brain is functioning
because it's not like
it it's not a
bandage
for one little area
the whole body is made up of these cells
that benefit from nutrition and you cut
that nutrition off
and everything is going to start
declining especially the brain
which
helps send all those you know those
little electrical pulses to make
everything work
yeah and of course you communicate with
people when they realize
frankie you're not communicating what's
going on here and so as opposed to
you're sitting there they can't tell
you're in pain unless you tell them when
you're in pain but when you can't talk
to them straight or you're mumbling or
you know you're complaining and all this
kind of stuff they know you've changed
and so you don't have to be much of a
diagnostician to know that somebody's in
trouble in their brain nutrition
that's right and that's one thing dr
wallach that i appreciate so much about
the education that is offered through
youngevity through you your programs
is it helps us to be armed with
information that we can share with
others whenever we see somebody that's
hurting
and
and i was thinking about it some
people's like oh well i don't want to
approach people because they'll just
think that i'm selling them something
well
you're selling health what's the doctor
doing they go to see a nurse what's the
nurse doing
you know they're pushing drugs that are
gonna mask different things
and not actually
work on the core foundation of the issue
and that's where you have done so much
research dr well i can finding out
what the body actually needs
because of
you've got what's 33 000 autopsies under
yours
yeah it's approaching that now it's a
well beyond 32 000
and of course um
i have 15 books i have 50 dvds and over
100 new cds including this new cd set
the health crisis in the church and i
have them working on a new book which
should be out before june i'm very
excited about this
now now you might say now this is you're
overstepping the bounds of this one
wally but the title is
the third testament
there's the old testament there's a new
testament and now this is the third
testament now i'm giving all the credit
to god i'm giving all the credit to the
old testament in the new testament and
there's a lot of stuff in there
extracted from those two wonderful
wonderful
collections of god's words
but there
it's been two thousand years since the
publishing of the new testament
two thousand years
i figured it was time to get that that
information out from two thousand years
gotta get that information out to people
because we have learned so much in that
two thousand years because of technology
they didn't have the technology we have
now and so they didn't know a lot of
things not because they were stupid okay
not because the raw material wasn't
there for them to learn
they didn't have the technology and the
machines and all the science and
everything we have now
and so i took all that science
and
uh and went back and did 2 000 years
worth of research
okay it took me about 10 years to do
this and i i toyed with the with the
title i mean what
this is going to be big
what what can the title be
and i say well let's see it's got to be
a support of the old testament in the
new testament let's call it the third
testament
okay and so that's how that came about
because it supports everything
the old testament says in the new
testament says all the heroes
uh they're in um both of those
testaments are still heroes okay uh it's
not but it's bringing new information in
to explain a lot of things that are in
those book wonderful books
okay the old testament in the new
testament
they could see things and they could
report them but they didn't have the
technology to tell you what caused them
and about them and how to eliminate the
problems and so forth so we have the
answers in the third testament so i'm
very very excited about this and we're
giving god all the credit
and it's going to be a what should i say
it's going to help
literally billions of people there's 7.9
billion people in the world rebecca
and i tell you that everything from
depression to physical ailments to
infections like you know the covet here
um
it's just
people who read this for me and give me
feedback they're freaking out they said
how come it took 2 000 years to get all
this stuff
[Laughter]
well that's because everybody was afraid
to go there well i've been going places
where no man has gone before
so many times
that i'm not afraid to go there
and you don't stop and we appreciate
that dr wallach
okay back to you
all right thank you and everybody thank
you for being here with us thank you for
joining us on a replay or joining us
live
you are watching askdoclive.com
this program is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com
website actually you're watching ask doc
live which is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
where you can find all of the
information and the replays from all of
our ass stock life almost all of our
askdoc live
programs since we began
in july of was it 2020
jaunty
is when we started this program which
it's hard to believe that it's been that
long but i love the fact that we've made
this library of information available to
the public
now if you were invited to watch this
program by somebody specific
make sure that you get back with them if
you have any questions in regards to the
content that was shared in this program
if you can relate to
somebody who comes on and presents
conditions that they're experiencing and
dr wallach gives the protocol
and solution for that get back with that
person say hey this person has some of
the same things that i'm going on the
doctor says i need
or i can't remember what the doctor said
i need your help to help me get those
products because let me tell you folks
if i hadn't have given 90 days
i can't believe that it's seven years
ago now
um
i would not be here today
so dr wallach's protocols have given me
my life back i'm no longer on
pharmaceuticals i'm no longer stuck in
bed
um and i'm no longer a hundred pounds
heavier so there's so much that can be
done through supplementation
and listening to dr wallach and
following his protocols has changed my
life and the lives of so so many so i
just can't thank you enough dr wallach
well we make a good team you and your
team and me and others
um our whole goal here is to get the
information out there so uh people who
are like-minded are going to use it we
you know we appreciate that everybody
doesn't listen to god and so if
everybody doesn't listen to god you
can't expect that everybody's going to
listen to us but you know we're looking
for for the for the wonderful people who
will listen to us
and it's one of those things where we
can't forget the kids and i i always
want to always make a remark for the
kids we have the kids toddy we have
the cherry men's and we have also the
the um
let's see here kids tidy cherryman's oh
um
and the kids sprinkles yeah you can put
the kids sprinkles on ice cream uh i
have some that i put on ice cream it's
actually vitamins and mineral um
sort of like beads they're covered with
dried berries and so kids love them you
know put a it comes in little sticks and
little individual packages in a box
and so uh i think they're green and red
and so you can just tear the top off and
sprinkle those on top of some ice cream
or on top of some uh rice or something
like that
right in the mouth
or right in the mouth right now
yeah the kids love them the grandkids
love them
well dr wellick we have some hands that
are up and i just want to remind
everybody who's on live with us
if you go to the zoom menu you will find
the option to raise your hand and if you
have a question that you would like to
come on and ask dr wallach
that is the way that you will get our
attention that you would like to ask a
question
we do have the comments also but please
raise your hand we want to make sure
that we get everybody and seeing you
live on camera helps dr wallick and his
questioning for you and the protocol
best for you
so let's first go to david
david go ahead and unmute
hi how are you doing
hey david we're here on live with dr
wallach david
i'm from uh indiana
okay how can we help you sir
uh four and a half years ago or four
years november i was diagnosed with a
chordoma uh which is
bone cancer
i've gone to
several doctors anyway the last
oncologist i went to he said that he was
floored
that i am as healthy as i am
when i was first diagnosed i the doctors
wanted to do chemo radiation surgery
none of those options appealed to me
especially the surgery
and they said all i was going to do was
add five years to my life
i'm four years down that road and
uh doctors like how can that be
and i said well you know i got a lot of
people praying for me and god's
answering those prayers but my question
to you is i want to make sure that i'm
doing
everything i can uh nutritionally and
supplementally
i've been using your products for about
a year or so
um but i want to make sure i'm doing
everything that i can to okay
maintain let me well let me ask you a
couple of quick questions here yes sir
and i can't i can't tell from the
picture here
um
do you have any gray or white or silver
hair
yes i do i'm 65 years old
65 and how much you weigh
uh 160.
160 yes sir
okay do you have any other issues any
hybrid pressure diabetes
no sir
okay do you have any joint problems
arthritis anything like that yes
okay
and so chordoma that tells me that it
was squeezing the spinal cord and
causing stuff
from your waist down or they said it's
cancerous
no that's that's not what i'm asking you
okay
i i heard that but
this is
in your bones in your back
it's in my sacrum
oh in your sacrum okay
and i have not lost any function
okay good
all right
and so but do you have pain from the
waist down yes
all right
okay so here we go
and some of this you're probably already
been doing here over the past couple of
years since you've been you know
involved with us but let's um for our
listening audience here
um
i need to get rid of all the bad foods
so you can maximize absorption stop
inflammation no fried foods no processed
meats no oils of any kind no gluten no
wheat no probably rhinos there are no
such things as gluten-free oats the
gluten and else is called gliadin
and then um let's see here no
um
let's see here uh oh also no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go
because the carbonation neutralizes
stomach acid so you cannot efficiently
digest food and absorb minerals
160 pounds i want you to have two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
two healthy brain and hard pass per
month full dose everything twice a day
that's our big hammer it has 215
nutrients in it so once you have two of
those
per month
they don't want you to have two bottles
a month or msm
i'm going to take three of those msm
tablets at breakfast lunch and dinner
you'll be able to do that with those two
bottles and they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone
microphone itself including the sacrum
okay and everything south of that
all right and then i also
want you to have
our collagen peptides i want you to take
one canister a month and that will allow
you to have one scoop with your
breakfast drink and one scoop with your
dinner drink and that's going to
support your immune system and your bone
marrow which is where your white blood
cells your antibodies are made to go
kill and eat viruses cancer cells and so
forth all right and so you want to be
sure to use that collagen peptides scoop
a breakfast
a drink and a scoop a dinner drink one
canister months will work for you for
that
then i also want you to have our fucoid
z capsules you can take three of those
twice a day that'd be two bottles a
month that's from seaweed from one ocean
and you can have seaweed and and um
uh
all
the green stuff for algae and
things like that that grow in the ocean
but i also want you to
in addition to that you have another
option we do have the liquid form of the
fucoid z it's called z radical
if you're going to use the k if you're
going to use the
liquid i want you to get two quarts a
month so you can take an ounce of
breakfast ounce of dinner you can use
the capsules there's two bottles a month
take three at breakfast through dinner
and that really supports the immune
system which is your best friend when
you have any type of cancer or
inflammation
and it also gives you these weird trace
minerals that are necessary to again
help the immune system
and i think that's where we're going to
start
you'll notice your hair color is going
to come back
it'll start coming back in about two to
three weeks after you start the program
but it's imperative to get rid of all
the bad foods everybody in the household
has got to be
gluten-free so there's no
cross-contamination in the laundry the
food preparation services
and
then the hair color starts coming back
people are going to say david are you
coloring your hair
your gray hair is going away okay no
okay because it's a nutritional
deficiency gray hair white hair silver
hair has nothing to do with aging
it's a nutritional deficiency and the
same nutritional deficiency causes
varicose veins hemorrhoids spider veins
it causes aneurysms
and so
you really really really want to be very
aggressive in eliminating all the bad
foods and taking all the good foods so
you can make sure you're getting
the
nutrients necessary for the hair color
to come back when the hair color comes
back you know you're on the right track
okay any last question before we go on
no sir thank you very much i appreciate
what you do and how you share your
information okay well thank you dave if
you would if you'd call us every couple
of weeks and give us an update we'd
appreciate it because people are going
to ask whatever happened to that david
guy from indiana okay
thank you sir god bless you you too okay
back to you rebecca
hello
rebecca oh she may be i am here and
thank you dr wallick and thank you david
david make sure that you stay in contact
with your amazing health coach because
she is awesome
um
now
dr welling
we have somebody who has ulcerative
colitis
uh stephanie writes it
and she
has a client named paula
sorry 65 year old female she's three
minerals and enzymes
sweeties and ultimate efa
she continues to have problems with
watery diarrhea she has no gallbladder
no tonsils no appendix she is diabetic
she has blood pressure issues
fibromyalgia degenerative disc disease
and arthritis nerve damage and afib
so dr like what is the full protocol
that paula needs to get on
including food choices to help her
overcome or address ulcerative colitis
okay ulcerative colitis is a classic
example of gluten
okay it's a disease caused by consuming
gluten and all these diseases that are
going on her colon and diarrhea and all
that kind of stuff
is due to gluten okay she's got to get
rid of all the bad foods and everybody
in the household including the dog and
the cat and the bird and the fish
everybody's gotta be dropped dead
gluten-free can't even say the word
okay
and then
uh 300 pounds
oh first of all because she has a fib
this is due to osteoporosis and skull
she needs to get my book it's called
it's all in your head you can go to
www.drjwalik.com www.drjwalk.com
get the book it's all in your head
goes into the 25 different diseases you
can get from afib
or excuse me from excuse me obviously
approach to the skull including afib
doctors want to treat it as a heart
disease but it's not the heart disease
is kind of like a
a symptom
okay what's going on in the skull
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve which
controls controls the right rhythm of
the heart
then let's see here 300 pounds i'm going
to give the ideal
um
need to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bread rhinos no
sugar no carbohydrate drinks of any kind
including the diet ones because the
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid
which is important for not only
digestion but also absorption
of minerals
and so she needs to do that and then i
want her to have three healthy brain and
heart pattern month three healthy brain
and heart packs per month a full dose of
everything three times a day a full host
of breakfast lunch and dinner i weigh
142 and i take two full doses a day at
142 pounds i take two healthy man hard
packs a month i take it full and i have
to pay for everything that the company
doesn't give me any free product i have
to pay for everything okay
and so
then i also want her to have uh two
bottles a month to the msm so you can
take three with breakfast through the
lunch at dinner time that's gonna
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone rick's bone itself
including the skull
and all the bones and every bone in her
body i also want her to have the
collagen peptides she can have one
canister a month of the collagen peptide
so you can take a scoop of that with her
drink in the morning and a scoop of that
with her drink in the afternoon
i also want her to have vitamin d3 three
of those three times a day
yeah even if she lives in florida she
doesn't get naked or in a bikini and lay
out in the sun for four hours every day
i guarantee if she sits in the shade so
she needs
to take the um
three of the
vitamin d3
uh three times a day that'll be three
bottles a month i want her to also have
the uh let's see here hair skin and
nails i want her to have hairs and skin
and nails she can take three of those
three times a day it'll be three bottles
a month of the hair skin and nails
and that's going to deal with all that i
also want her to have three bottles a
month of her ultimate daily classic
tablets you can take three with
breakfast through the lunch three dinner
time and they're going to support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries now did
you say she had diabetes also
yes
okay a diabetes she needs three bottles
a month
of our sweeties she could take three
breakfast three with lunch dinner time
and both the high blood pressure and the
diabetes if she's on medication for
those don't cold turkey off the
medication but test every day like she's
supposed to and as the blood sugar
begins to fall she can reduce the
medication based on the numbers and
usually it's within two to six weeks
she'll be totally off of her diabetic
medication because she won't be a
diabetic anymore
and then
um for the high blood pressure the same
thing don't call turkey off that
medication but as the blood pressure
begins to drop she can slowly reduce the
medication based on the numbers okay and
usually within
a month she'll be totally off of both
the medication for diabetes and hybrid
pressure uh did was she on dialysis for
her kidney issues
no not at this moment okay
okay well good that that's
just i get people off the dialysis
they've been on dialysis six days a week
for 10 years haven't urinated in 10
years and in two weeks time they're
urinating and and in six weeks time
they're totally off all their medication
you know they don't need dialysis
anymore after 25 years of being on
dialysis okay now remember the doctors
have kids in college and they require
income to pay for their tuition so
that's why they treat symptoms doctors
treat symptoms
doctors do not cure diseases doctors
treat symptoms and most patients are
very happy oh my god i was in so much
pain and doctors gave me this new
medication he said i'm the number one
the first one to get it they tell it to
everybody in the village you're the
first one to get it
and so they feel special
and it relieves
pain within hours and they're so happy i
had this pain for years and just in
hours it went away and it's a blessing
being pain-free is a blessing i'm not
i'm not
you know
saying that it's not a blessing but if
it's a disease that can be eliminated
so you don't need the medication to
relieve the symptoms
why not go there
that's what i say
okay back to you rebecca dr wallick i'm
going to say that also
that you know all of those things that
are just covering up symptoms
what do they do to the liver and the
kidneys dr wallach
well most medications have to be
detoxified
um in the liver and bits and pieces are
gotten rid of through the kidneys and so
it puts a strain on everything when
you're on the medication
and that's why they say well here are
side effects you need to watch out for
blah blah blah blah blah okay
and of course some side effects are
death
and so
um prescription drugs are potentially
very dangerous
and um and so people they're so excited
about being
free of the pain and free of some of the
nasty symptoms and things
that they're you know willing to take
that risk well you don't have to take
that risk if you're taking
your 90 essential nutrients and staying
away from the bad stuff so it can
maximize absorption
well it it it just
baffles me
that on that insert it says may cause
decreased kidney function may cause
liver failure may cause coronary disease
may cause heart attack
all of those things that may
is because it's happened in some of
their studies
yeah and not just once it's a
significant number of people who have
those side effects and that's why
they're listing them it just happened
one in a thousand they wouldn't list it
that's right
so i really encourage you folks if
you're on pharmaceuticals check out that
that sheet that comes with them and if
you're pharmaceutical prescription did
not come with that sheet say hey
i want to read the information that's
supposed to come with this
with this prescription
i want to read
all of the things that it benefits and
the things
that could happen
be informed
and i am so grateful dr wallach that i
got the supplementation that i
detoxified my kidneys and my liver so
that everything was functioning properly
i think that had a big part in my weight
loss
big part in
living without pain and i'll tell you
what
living without pain
is
incredible
absolutely incredible
yes and you you've been without pain for
eight years
seven years
almost seven years now
wow
yeah and yes it was an investment into
my own self
people say oh well i can't afford that
well
what can you afford when it comes to
later on
death is pretty expensive
yeah and not being able to be here for
your family mentally or physically
or
emotionally because your body is broken
down so much
that it just can't function properly or
you're taking energy something energy
that's a false energy just to help you
get through the day
well i love the fact that
with the nutriented body
i wake up in the morning
i'm ready to go i go throughout the day
and yeah i have my supplementations that
i take and i have a couple things that
when i need them
i have them but they're natural
in supporting my body and how it's
designed to work and doctor while like i
have access to all of those because of
you
what you have started
no you don't
make any income off the sell of the
products it all comes from your books
but you started this amazing company
that now has offered us
anyone it doesn't matter what your
background is it doesn't matter what
your education is
you can start your very own business
and with the education that's provided
through youngevity and through the
leadership within youngevity you can
have that confidence to be able to reach
out to people and say hey
i know this doctor he's had this amazing
research he's put together formulations
that have actually helped people
overcome things that you're going
through
would you like some more information and
it's that simple
it's that simple and
you're able to actually make an income
with a purpose in helping people and
improving lives and communities
so that's a beautiful
it's a beautiful story rebecca and i'm
gonna i'm going to say something here
which is going to flip people out now
now next month
is black history month
the entire month is black history month
and i have a book and a cd called
black gene lies because there's so many
diseases said to be genetic in the black
community there you go black gene lies
and all the diseases you know heart
disease kidney disease liver disease
brain disease
lung disease uh muscle disease joint
disease all these things none of them
are genetic and so we're going to have a
great time helping our black brothers
and sisters
um starting next week
specifically because we're going to
really go heavy
on the people of color and give them
information that's going to add many
healthful years to their life just like
you've had many healthful years added to
your life
and so thank you so much because we are
going to really really really
go to some of the famous people that we
have helped and some of the sort of the
average person that we have helped in
the black community
all over the world
and um it's amazing um the the results
we get
and uh this is gonna i'm already excited
about next month
well i'm excited that we have so many
people from around the world on with us
now i saw some of some of my business
partners pop in from from the uk
and from nigeria and from bahrain
you know and those are just some that i
know and i don't know where everything
you know where everybody's at so
the fact that
nutrition is not for
one demographic
everybody
needs it we were all designed by the
same creator
and we all need
the same nutrition
there's no walls there's no barriers
there's no prejudice here
you know we are one big happy family and
i'm gonna claim that happy
and and keep rolling with it so thank
you so much dr wallach for what you have
started with this
um in in the comments christy pook
i'm happy as stock live started
otherwise my life would have never
improved i've only been on the product
protocol for five plus months but i've
already had
huge improvements and i read the book
dead doctors don't lie years ago re-read
it last summer
which i have referred to frequently over
the years having this live program along
with the reruns on youtube has been
wonderful education
i still have a couple lingering
troublesome problems but i
am on this protocol for
life
so osteoporosis of the skull took years
to develop so it's not going to go away
overnight and that's right folks
it's not an overnight thing
it takes time
our cells are continually regenerating
and if i remember right it's seven years
of regeneration in every single belt but
uh cell in our body
is new
but the process continues to go so as
the process continues you have to have
the raw ingredients to make those
cells healthier
so the body can do what it was designed
to do
wow
great job
i have a little bit of a passion for
this doctor oh yeah
i guess let's go to our next hand up we
have five minutes before top of the hour
and pauline
pauline go ahead and unmute yourself my
dear
okay
you're on live with dr wallach hi paulie
hi doc
well um i'm 58
i'm 160
and um i'm 5'3
okay
what you got okay i'm anemic and i've
been anemic off and on
for most of my life
and i take an iron supplement
twice a day
but
it seems to never just
get to the number that my doctor wants
so i guess i'll be taking it for life
um i have high blood pressure and mitral
valve prolapse and i was diagnosed with
all of this um in my 40s my early 40s
okay so you've been dealing with drunk
for almost 20 years
yes
i have high cholesterol
now what's your number
i think he told me it was 259
it's too low it needs to be 350.
oh
just remember your doctor's got kids in
college and he needs the money
okay and the standard he he's changed my
stand four times because every time i
take it it gives me muscle aches so
he'll keep changing so i'm on one now
that i take
at night
every other day and that
so i have that okay yeah
okay
so you're talking about the medication
right
yes okay so here we go
um one other question do you have any
bowel problems any diarrhea constipation
anything like that
no not now i took i took meat out of my
diet about three years ago
and that kind of got rid of all of my
constipation mm-hmm
okay do you have any skin plums any
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
no
okay do any respiratory stuff any asthma
bronchitis
no but i do have slim
okay thank you
um
all right and anemic this is a standard
anemia just standard red blood cell
uh reduced kind of thing
yes correct okay so it's not sickle cell
and anything like that no no okay okay
okay well here we go
absolutely none of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat butter ions no sugar
no carbonated drinks you cannot cook
gluten for somebody else because you're
going to get cross-contaminated on the
food preparation surfaces and in the bed
and the couch and the moisture and dryer
and all that kind of stuff okay so no
gluten in the house even for other
people
okay
if they eat it outside the house make
them strip in the front yard and hose
them down before you let them in the
house
okay
it says is that serious
then at 160 pounds i want you to have
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy brain and heart packs
per month
um a full dose of everything at
breakfast a philosophy and dinner time i
want you to take two miles a month of
the msms and take three with each meal
that's gonna support and promote managed
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue including the bones
right
and bone matrix
and bone marrow cavity which makes the
red blood cells and platelets and white
blood cells and antibodies
and then i want you also to have the
collagen peptides put a scoop of that
the
powder in your drink in the morning a
scoop of that powder in your drink at
night one canister will last you a month
and then uh because of blood pressure
issues
and heart valve stuff
i also want you to take the um let's see
your ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day it'll be two
balls a month that'll support healthy
blood pressure healthy blood flow
and so on um then i also want you to
take
the
let's see there is something else i want
you to take oh
i need you to take the
um
either this z radical liquid
i want you to take um one quart
a month of the liquid you could take a
half ounce of breakfast and a half ounce
of dinner time if you take the capsules
you need two bottles a month so you can
take three of those capsules
of fucoid z which is a name for the
capsules of the z radical liquid okay so
that all comes from the same
um seaweed and so forth uh take three of
those twice a day either three capsules
twice a day or the half ounce of the
liquid z radical twice a day
and um
let's see here let's go there uh this
that's you know a lot to start with but
you're going to get benefit like you
can't believe because your bone marrow
it needs to get these nutrients to make
red blood cells
okay
and
the red blood cells have to be healthy
and made right so that they last 120
days so they're supposed to last 120
days but they have to be built in a
certain way
and so
they can't be fragile and they bust up
every time you make them your bone
marrow that squirts them out in your
arteries and then your arteries
pump them and they break because they're
too fragile okay and so let's do it all
right and then call us every two weeks
let us know what's going on do you have
white gray or silver hair
i do but i don't grade really quickly
but i do have some
okay you'll see that again that's not
old that doesn't mean it's not an aging
thing that is due to a nutritional
deficiency and so when the hair color
begins to come back
you know you know you know that you're
absorbing the nutrients okay
okay
there you go
okay thank you
god bless you
thank you
god bless you pauline
all right and i know for a fact that dr
wallace's protocol
for
anemia works because i had been anemia
anemic since i was 16 years old wow and
the doctor while i get 45 years old i
was no longer anemic what'd your doctor
say about that
they just said well whatever you're
doing
did they say come on sit down let's
let's sit down and have a cup of ice
cream or something here a cup of coffee
tell me what you're doing did they do
that no
they didn't
not at all
and see that's typical the doctor that
has a kid in college and needs the money
for tuition
well you've been my only doctor for the
last seven years so
for six and a half almost seven years it
and i have no desire to change because i
don't need one
but dr wellick we are at the top of the
hour so let's go ahead and take a five
minute break everybody thank you so much
for being with us on ask doc live
this program being brought to you by
asktalklive.com
we are here as a resource for you
so if you were invited to this program
by somebody specific make sure that you
get back with them and let them know
that you saw the program
and you want to get started on a
protocol
as i mentioned before it is an
investment but it's an investment into
you your greatest
asset in life because if you don't have
health how can you enjoy anything else
whether it be family whether it be
financial whether it be emotional
happiness
you need to have
and i try to remove the word need
i suggest
i encourage you
to find out what it feels like
to have a body that is fully nutriented
that is functioning the way it was
designed
your family will appreciate it as well
so everybody stick with us
i just also wanted to mention that all
of the books that are mentioned on
today's program can be found at
askdoclive.com
you can find dr wallach's books there
you can find all of our replays there
and you can also find the products that
dr wallach mentions
but again if you were invited by
somebody specific get back with them to
place your order
that shopping cart there
if you're a current longevity customer
you know your id number you can use that
shopping cart with with no problem but
we want to make sure that the person
that took the time to share this program
with you
has the opportunity to help you
get the products through the way that
they prefer to get them so everybody
stand up refill your drink and hey if
you have some collagen
mix it in there whether it's hot or cold
it's absolutely fabulous it does not
change the taste unless you've got
the collagen peptides for joint health
support which is fantastic or the
collagen for hair skin and nails which
is fantastic anyways we will be right
back with a stock live
and we are back with a stock live as
we're waiting for dr wallace to come
with us
i want to make sure that we get all of
your questions answered now there's a
few questions that want to know how do
we find out about the schedule for the
calls for speaking engagements for black
history month
get with your longevity distributor
if they don't have the information the
people
in their leadership will have the
information on being able to connect in
with the black history month schedule
also
if
you've got a loved one that's
suffering with some major
conditions
we cannot say do not go with to the
doctor
if it is a crisis con
situation then absolutely we have the
best
emergency medicine
system
that i can think of
but we're all about supporting the body
to be able to do what it was designed to
do
and to be able to
you know possibly
prevent those emergency situations
so we cannot say whether or not to or
not to go to the hospital but we do want
to make sure that everybody is getting
the information that they deserve that
supports their body
now doctor well like
let's go ahead and
let's get to the next hand that is up dr
wallach okay and that is treva
triva
go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with dr wallach
you should be able to unmute yourself
there we go
okay okay all right how can we help you
well i've recently had mris
i've had back issues for about three
years and the doctor said i have
fractures all the way down my spine
and so i just had a bone density test
yesterday
and i've already been warned he's going
to want to put me on some kind of
medication
and i was just wanting your
i'm already taking your products but i
want to know your opinion on
okay so how much you weigh in how old
are you
i'm 77 i
i lost 50 pounds so now i'm down to 104.
um and i lost a lot of inches i used to
be five too
what do you know
about four eight
okay so you lost six inches wow okay do
you have any ringing in the ears no
do you have any buzzing or roaring in
the ears no
okay do you have any balance problems or
vertigo
no
okay
uh let's see here do you have anything
going on in your hands and your wrists
no
what about your teeth do you have
dentures put in or
implants or anything like that
i have
i have a bridge
okay
all right uh let's see here but that
that's been for a long time
okay do you have anything going on um
uh do you have anything going on let's
see here in your bowels constipation
diarrhea
no
okay do you have anything going on in
your in like diabetes how about pressure
some high blood pressure
okay yeah now you have osteoporosis
okay terrible right including the skull
yes
um
we can't get you back six inches but we
might get you back an inch or two in
height
uh because we can help rebuild the disc
between your vertebrae we can get rid of
the hybrid pressure
okay your hair color will come back
because this is not due to aging hair
color is due to nutritional deficiency
okay
and so let's start
uh need to get rid of all the bad foods
and a lot of this you may be doing but
this you know needs to go to a lot of
people so i can get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat no butter
ryan oats no sugar no carbon or drinks
even the diet one's got to go because
it's carbonation
and the carbonated drinks it neutralizes
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals
so if you're taking just diet i'm just
taking diet drinks but still that
carbonation is neutralizing your stomach
acid i've never had a diet drink okay
good how about how much salt how much
salt do you take
i
i wasn't taking it but after
listening to my
con
consultant
consultant i i started thinking
the good side okay the pink himalayan
salt okay good the pink himalayan salt
from youngevity pink himalayan salt has
78 minerals in it okay
and you cannot absorb minerals without
without stomach acid and stomach acid is
made from
salt
salt is a raw material for chief cell in
your stomach to make stomach acid so
do you have any belching burping or
bloating
i do have bloating
okay yeah this is because uh you don't
have enough uh you don't have enough
stomach acid so bacteria are fermenting
your food in your belly and causing the
bloating okay so i want you to get our
pink himalayan salt
and use a half a teaspoon of breakfast
and half a teaspoon of dinner time okay
with the pink himalayan salt it wouldn't
hurt to do it three times a half a half
a teaspoon of breakfast lunch and dinner
of the pink himalayan salt from
youngevity
all right well here we go
need to get rid of all the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bread rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks you know that
one's got to go and this is for
everybody else i know you don't do some
of that but that's for everybody else
also
then um you need to take it 104 pounds i
want you to take one healthy brain and
heart pack per month then once you get
another bottle of art selenium one
bottle of selenium comes with the health
abandoned heart pack take a half a dose
of everything twice a day except for the
selenium once you take six a day you can
take two two and two or three and three
whatever is easier for you the selenium
it has five cofactors added to it not
selenium from
walmart but arthelene has the five
cofactors in there
and your hair color will start coming
back that tells me you're absorbing okay
when your hair color comes back
then
and um let's see here then uh you're
gonna start growing again you'll you'll
regrow
an inch or two you're not going to
regrow six inches but you'll regrow an
inch or two because your disc will be
healed
all right and then i want you to take
our msm get one bottle of msm so you can
take three twice a day one bottle of msm
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone breaks
your bone itself including the skull the
walls of the arteries the walls of your
veins
all right and then i also want you to
take the collagen peptides take a scoop
of that with your morning drink and take
a scoop of that with your evening drink
uh that's one canister a month of the
collagen peptides that's actually
cartilage
and connective tissue from fish poultry
sheep and beef
and so it's one of those miracle
nutrients okay it's it's it gives your
body what it needs for all the things
you're missing
okay and then because of high blood
pressure don't you have
two uh bottles a month our ultimate day
daily classic tablets two bottles a
month the ultimate daily classic
challenge you get three twice a day
and the ultimate daily classic tablets
will support healthy blood pressure
are you on medication for the blood
pressure
yes okay don't cold turkey off the
medication but you know check your blood
pressure every other day or every day
and as your blood pressure begins to
drop you can slowly reduce the
medication okay based on the numbers
don't just say okay i'm on this now i
can throw away my medication no do it by
the numbers okay
now again i apologize i asked you this
but i forget the answer uh do you do you
have diabetes no
okay good
very good all right
then let's see here i um also want you
to have the fucoid z you can have three
of those capsules twice a day there's
two bottles a month that's from the
seaweed in one ocean uh if you prefer
the liquid you can get a quart of the z
radical which is the liquid form of the
few point z and you can take a half
ounce of that twice a day
and it gives you what's necessary to
support your immune system and also give
you raw materials that'll help also your
hair color come back because it's got
some of the raw materials in it
necessary for the hair color to come
back
and i think we're covering all of those
things that you're complaining about
um
i wouldn't hurt to have
a
get some gluten-free ice cream
i have i have
um a third of us of a pint of
gluten-free ice cream every night with
dinner
okay
and what is that
what brand is that gluten-free ice cream
um
you know
i don't know because it's given to me
um
okay
but all right it's it's it's it's it's
the biggest brand in the store
i think it's breyer's
is that so right no no
no well then maybe they may have gluten
free but that's not the one that i'm
using it's not virus no
now what do i tell the doctor who wants
to put me on medication
okay say well i'm trying some things i
want to wait
wait he wants to put you on medication
for what
for for osteoporosis oh okay so no
give me 90 days i'm working on this i
you know i have a nutritional plan i'm
going to here
so since this is a nutritional
deficiency disease i don't want a
pharmaceutical okay just out give me 90
days if i'm not successful in 90 days
i'll come to you for the for the for the
drug
okay because that
that's my concern because i know some of
these drugs are really bad i mean most
people well yeah you can yeah well ask
him which one are you going to give me
see i'm going to look it up
and see what all the side effects are
okay
yeah well that's he said there are
several drugs out there
we'll do the bone density test and then
i'll i'll tell you which one we're going
to put you on
and it's like
i would rather do it nutritionally
yeah okay well there you go
so yeah
you know give us a call every couple of
weeks because you know i always tell
people give us 90 days because you're
going to see if you're doing everything
right you'll begin to see things going
right in the beginning but it's not like
all or nothing it goes improvement
improvement improvement improvement
and so
um you'll be improving you'll be able to
see improvement within two weeks and
then four weeks and six weeks and eight
weeks
and then by 90 days i mean you're going
to feel like you're you're 18 years old
again
well i've been on your products for a
while so
gluten-free gotta be gluten-free yeah
well i
yep
that's i shop for that
all right well thank you thank you
thank you treva for coming on with us um
i've had multiple compression fractures
myself so i understand the pain and
discomfort that you're in
so my prayers and thoughts are with you
now dr wallach the next question is
coming from jill and she has a client
who's 48 years old weighs
175 pounds at five foot tall she has
several severe nutritional deficiencies
in every category of health so
with the
health coaching program we do have a
health evaluation that gives an actual
health score her health score is a
negative one
she has
gastroparesis due to nerve damage to her
stomach related to type 1 diabetes
type one diabetes was diagnosed at the
age of six
we're asking for your thoughts on
gastroparesis and whether anything can
be done to improve it
she has seen many positive changes with
following an anti-inflammatory diet
however she doesn't believe anything can
be done with gastroparesis
that's very easy to get rid of
gastroparesis is a simple nutritional
deficiency it's one of the symptoms
of osteoporosis of the skull it's a
squeezing of the tenth cranial nerve the
vagus nerve by the skull
it goes runs all the way from the brain
all the way down to the stomach and
causes gastroparesis you know when it's
being squeezed
she might also have an irregular
heartbeat a fast heart rate does she
complain about any of that
he does not complain about any of that i
doesn't say that there's any type of
heart conditions here okay good well
it's actually not a heart condition it's
a heart i don't should call it a symptom
or something because the same nerve
that's being squeezed that causes
gastroparesis it's the same nerve that
causes
heart issues and doctors think it's a
heart problem but it's really just
osteoporosis of the skull
okay so here we go
um
gotta get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat fryer i know it's
not sugar no carbohydrate drinks even
the diet one's gotta go
and then at 175 pounds i wanted to have
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two health abandoned hard packs
per month full dose everything twice a
day
and then i wanted to have two bottles a
month of our msm so she can take three
at breakfast three at lunch at a time
and they're gonna
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue including in the brain and the
skull
um in the heart valves um in in the
bones in the disc between the vertebrae
joints every place okay
that's the msm and then i wanted to have
the collagen peptides take a scoop of
that with a breakfast every morning and
a scoop of that was her inner drink and
a scoop of that in her drink at dinner
time
that's going to help her immune system
as well as
make red blood cells white blood cells
for her
and her antibodies for her immune system
and so forth and also for the walls of
arteries and veins and so on
and then for type 1 diabetes diagnosed
at 6 that's kind of iffy
okay but i'm assuming she's been on
medication since she's six years old is
that correct
i'm gonna say yes her her distributor is
on the line with us we can go ahead and
ask her to unmute and she'll know that
question okay answer to that okay go
ahead
i actually don't know the answer to that
because she did her health evaluation a
while ago and i was simply trying to
follow up on the gastroparesis but i
remembered that she told me that she was
six
um and that's all i know i have to get
more information okay and so yeah
doctors will sometimes
diagnose a type 1 diabetes when they're
that's because they give them an oral
medication
and
they cannot absorb it because they're
eating gluten
okay and so well you're type one no
they're type two they just couldn't
absorb the metformin because it's an
oral medication because they have type
one
um
uh excuse me they have a gluten issue
okay
no gluten
you can't cook for anybody else you
can't cook gluten for somebody else
because you're going to get
cross-contaminated in the laundry and
the food preparation services etc
okay then
i wanted to have the few coins the three
of those
twice a day that's two bottles a month
of the capsules if she prefers a liquid
um she could take
two quarts a month because she's 175
pounds she needs two quarts a month uh
be an ounce of breakfast ounce at dinner
time it's from the seaweed
and algae and
all that kind of stuff from the ocean
all this weird trace minerals and
everything that's in there
and for the for the diabetes i'd give
her the ultimate excuse excuse me give
her the sweeties uh she should have two
bottles a month at the sweeties take
three of those at breakfast for dinner
time
and then you know take her blood sugar
and see how that's going and then
um as her blood sugar begins to drop
um
then she can
if if it's truly type one it'll drop but
not all the way it might drop
90 and to have just a little residual
blood sugar issue
but any rate as the blood sugar begins
to reduce or yeah it would come down she
can reduce the amount of medication
she's taking slowly slowly slowly yeah
not cold turkey okay
and then
uh let's see here
um see this is going to help her joints
it's going to help her heart her blood
pressure her diabetes
and so let's go there
and by doing this and getting rid of all
the bad foods she's going to lose some
weight and
she's only five foot tall
i'd like to see her weigh 85
85 pounds to um a hundred pounds so
she's got to lose 75 pounds
she's way overweight almost double what
she should weigh
okay but she will begin to lose weight
as as soon as she starts getting off of
all these bad foods and she's taking the
supplements so she's not going to be
hungry so her meals will be smaller
simply because when you're nutritionally
deficient you have a behavior called
pica p-i-c-a which drives you to eat
more eat more eat more eat more eat more
and
it's one of those things where once you
start supplementing
the pica behavior goes away you can look
it up in any dictionary p-i-c-a
um
and when the pica goes away you're
satisfied with a small meal
and so you don't gain weight you know um
i'm 83 years old and only weigh 142
pounds i'm five foot six
and
um
i played football i wrestled
uh ran long distance track and all kinds
of stuff so i you know i've led a full
physical life
uh but i'm small
um this just you know that's that's what
i was given
so to speak okay so anyway let's hear
from you um every couple of weeks
all right thank you doc appreciate it
okay thank you
thank you dr welcome thank you jill now
one thing that i want to
mention is
doing some mild strength training and
nasima our amazing co-host um has a lot
of experience with this she had
mentioned that the strength training
exercises can help with bone density
when using the nutrients
so dr wallach you all always say
exercise without supplementation is
suicide well
we're getting that supplementation right
folks
so we're going to be doing some gentle
strength training to help keep our bones
strong
and that could be as simple as taking
soup cans in each hand
and doing movements
putting them on your ankles and doing
leg lifts
it's super
simple and it does not have to be
strenuous this is that great doctor that
is correct thank you for bringing that
up because i walk three miles a day
i walk a mile and i have lots of stuff
to do for an hour so then i walk a mile
again and i have stuff to do and i walk
them out for the third time every once
in a while on the weekends on saturday
and sunday they might walk four miles
okay i've been doing that for 75 years
and uh you know in addition to yard work
and all that kind of stuff
but yeah i do have a cd out called
exercise without supplementation of
suicide i have another cd out that's
called dead athletes don't lie because
everybody tells me well you know i
exercise well that's good but you still
need your 90th cents nutrients in fact
because you're exercising you need you
really need the 90 cents nutrients
because you're going to sweat them out
you're going to sweat those nutrients
out and so you do need to make sure well
my doctor says i can get everything i
need by just eating well well your
doctor needs to go to jail you cannot
get everything you need by just eating
well because plants only get fertilizer
with three nutrients in it npk
and your body needs 90. we're going to
get the other 87 okay
and so you can you cannot get what you
need just by eating well that's nonsense
um
so and eating well eating well to the
usda pyramid is not eating well
according to what you have found out to
be
what are the good foods and bad foods
that is correct you still need to adhere
to the good food bad food list
and you can find that list on
askdoclive.com
now just as a reminder this program is
being sponsored by askdoclive.com
if you have questions that and you do
not have a distributor that you're
working with you can go to our website
use the contact us and submit questions
there but i do encourage you to get back
with
the person that shared this program with
you because if they are not a
distributor they may be associated with
one that can help you get your questions
answered
now for those who have never ever tried
any of the youngevity products and you
would like to speak with somebody before
placing an order
for supplementation because i know dr
wallach he's going through a lot of
products and he speaks very quickly so
you can go back and watch the replay so
that you can get those products written
down but we do have a call team
available at 855-949-7234
now again those are for
people who have never ever
spoken to anybody about youngevity
they've never ordered before and you
have questions before and uh placing an
order
dr wallach let's go to our next guest
with their hand up and john
john go ahead and
unmute yourself
it looks like you are unmuted john
okay am i unmuted yes
okay great
good morning doc good morning doctor
good morning sir how can we help you
um
i would um
i've got some issues and i do understand
that
you can probably help me basically uh
you i am let me see i am six foot
six foot three
i weigh uh
260 pounds
i am 68 years old
i do have um white hair and it is
thinning
um
i've i've got a
blood cut clot conditions
i've got deep vein thrombosis
and in the past 10 years i've had
four pulmonary embolisms
i do have um
glaucoma i do notice um
floaters and like spots my vision isn't
clear up close it's a bit blurry
i do i do wear corrective glasses but
most times i take them off because they
don't
seem to do well for me
do you have any high blood pressure
diabetes
you know uh
i'm i worked on my diabetes and i'm no
longer diabetic i'm i do understand the
sugar issues and the gluten and i'm
i'm just about off those completely i
realize that's a very necessity
as far as the um
the food
and i i work to have my plate about a
quarter of the plate as protein and
three-quarters vegetables i have
vegetables in every meal
and um
okay do you have anything do you have
any skin problems
uh no but i do have spider veins on my
around my ankles okay well that goes
along with white hair okay white gray or
silver hair they're both the same
nutritional deficiency
and they can cause a lot of problems
that that nutritional deficiency is not
that that doesn't occur because of aging
um let's see here also
um do you have anything
uh going on with your bowels any
constipation diarrhea anything like that
you know i have
no problems there
okay any respiratory stuff at this point
any asthma bronchitis copd
well i i i basically last 10 years i've
had four pulmonary embolisms
no no i'm talking about respiratory part
oh okay
you know when i was a child when i was
before puberty i did have uh asthma but
okay
after you grew up okay
okay okay
all right um
let's see here i think that covers oh do
you have any ringing in the ears any
balance problems vertigo balance
problems ringing in the ears
no sir
okay good
all right do you have any dentures
implants for your teeth
i do i do have some root canals and i do
have um
um
i can't think what it's called now but
it's basically where they go into the
bone and they put a
an anchor in there then they they put a
an appliance on top of it
yeah an implant okay yeah sure
well here we go um
you need to get at six foot three 260
pounds if you're a weight lifter and
everything you could be okay the six
foot three i'd like to see away about
230 might be a little overweight okay
and so you need to get off all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat no brother i
know it's no sugar no carbohydrate
drinks even the diet one's got to go for
energy i want you to use our rebound or
sports drink with a hundred nutrients in
it okay and that's a totally different
than the soft drinks
and i want you to use our salt i want
you to use our
pink himalayan salt
because it makes
it's a raw material for your stomach to
make
stomach acids so it can digest properly
and so forth all right
and
uh gastroparesis stuff okay
um then i want you to
um
let's see here understand that you
probably have osteoporosis of the skull
which can cause glaucoma by squeezing
the optic nerve the optic artery the
optic vein
and it's really not an eye problem it's
the skull squeezing the optic nerve the
optic vein the optic artery
dealing with blood going in blood coming
out and so forth into the eye
and out of the eye
all right and then um
i want you to
take
a 260 you're right at that cusp
the finances are not a problem i'd have
you take three healthy brainerd heart
packs for months to full dose everything
at breakfast lunch and dinner if
finances are an issue don't go any lower
than two healthy being in hard packs for
months and full dose everything twice a
day but ideally you would take a full
dose three times a day until you lose
that weight
okay
and then i also want you to have two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three with breakfast three with the
lunch read dinner time they're designed
to support and promote mains repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the rotary bone
makes the bone itself
and
the the healthy brain heart pack that
has the nutrients in it that are missing
when you have blood clots so the blood
clot issue should be reduced
significantly
or even eliminated because you're gonna
be taking those three ideally you'll be
taking those three healthy brain and
heart packs uh there's nutrients in
there which will
significantly reduce or prevent totally
blood clots and and um
that sort of stuff okay
um and people say well well why don't
you tell me which one it is so i can
just go get those well that's because
you'll be 89 sharp and and
it won't work okay
you need to take you need to take the
whole picture so for those people out
there i'm saying it the way i'm saying
it so they won't just run out and buy
that one nutrient okay
of course not okay
and then
uh you know you can get the books you
get the book it's all in your head
which will go into that sort of stuff um
that book covers 25 different diseases
that are caused by osteoporosis skull
and then also
we have the book epigenetics which goes
into oh for
i don't know several hundred different
diseases that are caused by nutritional
deficiencies
uh and so you know kind of you need some
information here and then don't forget
our new
cd set health crisis in the church two
cds other the soundtracks off of two
zooms i did in texas on the subject of
the um
uh
the crisis was the covid stuff the delta
and the omicron variants uh in texas in
the churches and house affecting in the
church community and so on
and then let's see here
let's see here you have no diabetes no
high blood pressure
correct
yes sir that's correct
okay
and so okay
then um one other thing just for kicks i
think i said the
fucoid z three of those
three times a day there's three at
breakfast field entry there are ten
that'll be three bottles a month or if
you won't prefer the liquid form of the
fucoid z
which is from the algae and and that
sort of stuff from the ocean all the
weird trace minerals and everything uh
you can get two quarts of the liquid z
radical and take an ounce of breakfast
out to dinner time so either either one
of those will work don't forget
our colloidal silver two droppers full
under your tongue 30 minutes for each
meal and 30 minutes for a bedtime it's
going to kill viruses bacteria fungus
and yeast don't forget our hand
sanitizer
you leave the house you come back in the
house take that hand sanitizer with you
especially if you're going to be eating
out or visiting somebody and opening
doors
in vehicles and
buildings and rooms and houses and
bathrooms and so forth like in the
church everybody goes in and out of the
bathrooms everybody's handling those
doorknobs if you really need in a church
you need those hand sanitizers because
there's so many people in there who
knows which one or which ones
are shedding virus because they have an
active infection okay
and so with that any any last questions
before we move on here
i really appreciate your time i'll get
started on this once i get started
yeah call us every two weeks yeah yeah
get back to us every two weeks john
because people are going to want to know
whatever happened to that john guy okay
yeah it'll probably take me that a
couple weeks maybe to get all my all the
supplements and get going thank you very
much doctor okay god bless you sir bless
you also
okay rebecca
let's just go ahead and move right on to
kathy kathy go ahead and unmute yourself
and if you're able to turn a camera on
and join us that would be fabulous as
well
hi um actually i don't have my cameras
set up right now but my question is
actually a veterinary question about
okay well stop stop a minute where are
you from
i'm from denver
okay
that's the denver in colorado
yep denver colorado
okay
okay what kind of a venerate question
you have
i have a um not quite 10 year old bengal
mix
and um now are you talking wait a minute
are you talking about a can't read
the time okay you're not talking about
tiger
the house cat kind
and uh he was over the summer he was
diagnosed
with
um myotrophic
uh let's see or hcm
hypertrophic myocarp myocarditis okay
um
that he is currently on
hymoted in
twice a day morning and night
uh a potassium supplement at night
and
what does he weigh
he weighs about 15 pounds okay big boy
yeah he's a big boy he's he is a big boy
he's he's a little overweight but he is
about 16 inches from the collar to the
base of his tail
okay
all right well i'm going to go ahead
with this
you know we do we do have
um
let's see here are arthur decks for
animals
and it's
one scoop one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight so i'd go ahead and just
give him one scoop since he had a health
challenge here i'd give him one scoop of
our um arthur dex i'd also get a bottle
of our selenium and open up the the
capsule and give him a castle
of um
of the um
selenium you know the powder mixed in as
food as well as the arthrodex
and
it's one of those things where
um
the myocarditis and and
cardiomyopathy it's all the same
diseases different people call it
different names but it's all caused by
nutritional deficiency
and this is easily within weeks it goes
away when you supplement properly but
read the read the label on the cat food
make sure there's no gluten in there
make sure there's no wheat butter rye or
oats in the cat food
and whether it's dry or canned
okay i prefer the can because you can
mix in the
the supplements and stuff like that
easier
all righty
okay um now he is on a um he uh has
shown some signs of beginning the kidney
disease so they do have him on a kidney
diet
okay
um
then just make sure that it's
gluten-free
okay
gotta read the labels make sure it's
gluten-free
and then
because they do have
canned cat foods they're specially made
for
kidney disease cancer okay
yeah
okay and just make sure there's no
gluten in it no wheat by the way our
oats
and then um it's one of those things
where
uh
if he does have kidney disease then it
wouldn't hurt also to throw in let's see
here our ultimate daily classic tail
it's just one of those you have to have
to grind it up it's a it's a tablet you
have to grind it up and throw that in
the food also okay
all right thank you very much okay then
give it give us a call every couple of
weeks and then let us know how how
uh our tiger is doing okay
okay all right thank you you bet bye bye
thank you kathy and thank you dr wallach
let's move on to charlene
charlene go ahead and unmute yourself
and if you're able to start video that
would be fantastic as well
oh you do have it
okay now try to unmute charlene people
move around on my little list
let's try a mute one more time do you
see a little pop-up there
you should be able just to click the
unmute
microphone at the bottom of the screen
do you see it
charlene wait can you hear me
if you can do your head up and down
yes okay go ahead and unmute my dear
all right well while you're looking for
that
we're gonna move to
i'm sorry i'm not able to understand
what you're what you're saying
but let's can you unmute do you see the
unmute option
no
all right well keep looking for that
we'll come to you after jill
so jill did we just get it done with
jill
this is another jill another jill
this
is another jail
i am can you hear me now
yes ma'am go right ahead hi hi dr
wallace and rebecca oh i'm having a
terrible echo
can you hear me
still it's a little bit
it's a little better but it's still
echoey
get closer or farther or something
yeah try moving just a little bit closer
and that should help and go right ahead
okay
how's that
any better
let's try it it's still echoey but let's
try it okay i'm sorry okay i'll try to
make it quick then um so i am let's say
i've got two uh hopefully
straightforward questions i'm 127 pounds
five okay so we'll go back to the weight
how much does the weight
127.
okay
five three and a half okay
60 age 66
um
i take no medications
um i'm on europe do you color your hair
yes i do
and it is gray
okay
um i take your supplements
um
your you know like the healthy start
pack plus a number of other things you
know like the msm
selenium
you know a number of extra things on top
of that
so what's your what's your question
two actually uh so one uh in a recent
wellness check
my doctor said my thyroid level
just went over the
the high end of the normal range it is
five and she wants to immediately put me
on medication
so okay
all right
well thyroid is very easy it responds
very quickly
um
again this is you're probably doing a
lot of this but this is for our
listeners as well
um need to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat no ryan oats no
sugar no carbonated drinks but also
because you have a thyroid issue
you need to stay away from cruciferous
vegetables no cabbage broccoli
cauliflower brussels sprouts or kale
that's away from them because they
interfere with thyroid function
then at 127 pounds i want you to have
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month get another bottle of our selenium
there's one bottle of selenium in the
aldebaran hard pack but i want to get
another bottle of slime so you can take
six a day
uh two two and two or three and three
whatever is easier for you
then i also want you to have
our fucoid z capsules take three of
those twice a day two bottles a month i
want you to take our oceans gold
capsules take three of those twice a day
that's two bottles a month
and um
you'll notice your hair color will begin
to come back
and so that means you're absorbing and
the thyroid will show an improvement
within
10 days to 14 days and within
um within uh
six to eight weeks it'll be totally
normal so how long do you have to stay
on this stuff
well how long do you need oxygen how
long do you need water you need to stay
on this stuff forever this is not like
well i can i just need oxygen you know
well i have a cold and then when i don't
have a cold i don't need oxygen anymore
you know you need these things all the
time and the mistake people make is i
was doing fine
and then you know three months after i
stopped the supplementation my problems
all came back well that's because
you're still missing these nutrients you
know they don't just come
you know from um
which they say
exercise exercise while supplementation
is suicide
right so that help you out
yes yes i hope so i mean
no okay it gives you a program and if
you do if you follow all that and stay
away from the bad foods to absorb
everything then you're going to have a
blessing all right
okay thanks so much doctor okay thank
you jill
bye
bye-bye thank you geo
and
let's try charlene one more time
let's see if you can unmute
you should get a little pop-up that asks
if you
or says that the host would like to
unmute you and all you have to do is say
yes
or click yes
no
let's move on
um all right let's go to jacqueline
jacqueline go ahead and unmute yourself
hello
you are on live with dr wallach hi how
are you hi
how do we help you
so i have um
i am 195 pounds i'm 38 years old
um i at one point was diagnosed with
lupus and rheumatoid arthritis however
i um
never had like stop a minute stomp him
at you slurred there did you say
rheumatoid arthritis yes alright okay
and lupus
and lupus okay yep and then um i saw a
rheumatologist for a while i was on a
ridiculous amount of medicine and i
stopped all that and started taking like
essential oils and for the most part got
rid of everything however once in a
while i have really bad arthritis
um and it will be
anywhere in my body um my back is an
excruciating pain from a herniated disc
and
i also was diagnosed with really really
bad anemia
okay
all right these are all simple
nutritional deficiencies diseases um the
only thing is i'm vegan so there's that
too
okay
even vegans need the 90 essential
nutrients
yep got it okay
so here we go none of the bad foods no
fried foods because you can still fry
vegetables and grains and stuff like
that can't do it no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by rhinos no wheat by rhinos no
wheat butter anodes there are no
gluten-free wheat brother arrows you
have to eat like an asian eat rice and
beans and squash
got it
yep
okay
then i want you to have eggs there's no
meat in eggs why don't you have three
eggs
oh no you're not you know how many
different eggs there are in the market
you may be allergic to chicken eggs but
there's duck cakes there's goose eggs
there's um guinea eggs
you need eggs otherwise you're in
trouble
okay because you need the cholesterol
because you're not eating meat so you
need the cholesterol cholesterol makes
up 75 of your brain weight cholesterol
makes up 95 of estrogen
okay
so you need to go in that direction
then
i want you to let's see here
i want you to have get rid of all the
bad stuff we just said that none of the
bad stuff i'm recommending three eggs
twice a day with soft yolks soft balls
soft boats soft poached us um
and that little white dot does one
millimeter in diameter sitting on top of
the yoke when you crack a raw egg that's
the chick you can take that off and
flush him down the toilet and say a
prayer for him and bury him at sea kind
of thing
because the rest of the egg is all just
plant material
okay the yolk of the egg and the white
of the egg is nothing but plant material
there's no meat in the egg except in
that one little disc is the chick and in
26 days it'll be a chick with eyes and
brain and muscles and heart and lungs
and
it's an amazing thing that egg but
there's all these different eggs okay so
try something really weird like
like eggs from um
a ducks duck eggs try that because you
may be allergic to chicken eggs let's
try duck eggs
okay so anyway then i want you to uh
when you have lupus is this a skin
problem and respiratory
no it's mostly um like arthritis wise
and um sometimes like asthma and stuff
well that's a lung problem okay asthma
is one problem okay all right
so then i want you to
um take let's see 195 pounds once you
take two healthy brain and heart packs a
month two healthy brain and heart packs
per month full dose everything twice a
day
and then i want you to have
two bottles a month of our msm i want
you to take three of those with
breakfast three with the lunch for
dinner time and they're designed to
support and promote mains repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a vertebrae bone
makes your bone itself
okay there's all back stuff and hip
stuff and joints all over the place
um you require that stuff that's in the
msm also you want to get our
collagen peptides which is
cartilage and ligaments intended as a
connective tissue there's no meat in
there is there shellfish because i'm
allergic to sugar no well no shellfish
machine telling us it's made from
um
fish you know with scales not shellfish
but fish with scales
um
um and also from um
let's see here uh
poultry
sheep and beef okay and you can put a
scoop of that you start out you know
gingerly put a start out with a half a
scoop in your drink in the morning start
with a half a scoop and drink in the
evening
um but you know your supplement drink
but you really want to work towards
getting a full scoop of that collagen
peptides at breakfast and dinner
alrighty and then
let's see here vitamin d3 i want you to
take three of those twice a day where do
you live
colorado
oh okay
and so yeah colorado's good
but you still need the vitamin d three
three of those twice today so you can
absorb the minerals and put them in all
the proper places
if you need something for topical pain
relief we have the cm cream and we also
have the soothe which is a little pump
bottle it's our cbd oil to make dr oz
jealous okay
and um
uh let's see here i think that's where
you want to go
my question is
i still have to take these things even
though i'm vegan like i i can't
well then suffer
there's no other there's no other
options either you take the nutrients to
solve the nutritional deficiencies are
you have to suffer and you just take the
pain relief
but it'll take
50 of your life off
okay the nutrients are required to
maximize your lifespan
if you're prepared to give up 50 years
of your life and be miserable between
now and then then don't take the
supplements
as your choice but there's no other
options
all right thank you
okay
see you're getting a coaching back there
um
all right thank you jacqueline hopefully
that was beneficial it does make a world
of difference
let's yeah yeah it's one of those
it's one of those things where
extremely limiting your diet and
expecting to not have to supplement is
is not you know
reality
all right dr wallach we have
jane back with us jane go ahead and
unmute yourself
jane
jane we only have about five minutes dr
wallach so how are you doing jane
um i guess i'm at the point of suffering
i suddenly got
ill and
i i just couldn't even take the
the 90 essential of vitamins
i
cut it down to
one
okay we'll start out stop
let's go i see you have white green
silver hair oh
yeah so what else you got going well
if i take the whole line of vitamins
i've i've actually been throwing up at
dinner i just
i suddenly am collapsing and okay
okay stop
okay now do you have a balance problem
is are you collapsing because of a
balance problem or a weakness
it's
my again my bottom legs are
you know weaker
they're weak
okay and i'm trying to take the uh
and the sweeties and then okay well
don't don't start with a full dose and
start out with one tablet twice a day
all right just start out with one of go
back to one of each
mm-hmm all right
you got to start somewhere right
right and i said you have to start
somewhere
because
yeah because you're if you're falling
it's your age how old are you
um i just turned 80.
okay good girl well at 80 you fall down
you break something you're dead
okay and so you don't want to be falling
down and all that kind of stuff so you
need strength to be able to maintain
yourself do you use a walker or a cane
or anything like that no
no you need to get yourself a walker
or a cane so that you have some support
so you don't fall down and break
something then you'll really be in
trouble
okay so here's um for our listeners uh
how much do you weigh
i'm down to around 100
and 96. i've had problems with this
wait a minute wait a minute did you say
166 or 106. 10106.
106. okay
all right so i want you to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed needs no oils no glutens no
wheat no butter rhinos no sugar no
carbon drink so you can absorb the
nutrients then i want you to have one
healthy brain heart peppermint take a
half a dose of everything twice a day
start out there
and then i also want you to get the msm
and start out with one tablet twice a
day start out there i want you to get
the collagen peptides
i start out with a
half a teaspoon in your morning drink
and your evening drink uh that's going
to help you with your immune system but
also your bone marrow so you can make
plenty of red blood cells and platelets
you ever get any bleeding under your
skin anything like that
no
okay good are you ever anemic
um
i could be
i haven't really had a full blood test
i don't okay
okay
full-time physician so well that's good
you don't want a full-time physician you
want once in a lifetime position
okay
uh so anyway
a half a teaspoon is you mean a regular
half or half a scoop no i want you to
start with a half a teaspoon twice a day
of the collagen peptides you want to
grow into a scoop twice a day
let's start out with a half
right because you said you're having
difficulties in taking supplements
absolutely
you start out with a small dose to begin
with and get used to that and you'll
improve and then you can go up a step
and go up a step until you're at the
full dose okay
don't don't just jump from zero to a
full dose when you're having problems
okay
okay that makes sense
yeah
okay should do the sweeties and the uh
are you a diabetic
i think i'm a pre-diabetic
okay do you fall asleep after you eat
i do sometimes yes okay that's reactive
hypoglycemia that's a pre-diabetes thing
so it wouldn't hurt to get a bottle of
sweeties so you can take one of those
twice a day start with one sweeties
twice a day
and let's see here any blood pressure
issues
yes i've had blood blood pressure
forever okay okay so then you want to
take one
um
let's see
one ultimate daily classic tablet twice
a day one at breakfast one dinner time
and then work up but that'll be a place
to start that's gonna support a healthy
blood pressure and and
um through the diabetes of sweeties one
of those twice a day that's going to
help healthy blood sugar levels all
right
and then you know give us a call every
couple of weeks or any time you have a
question
and but i would suggest you get a cane
or a you know a little aluminum walker
they only weigh like two pounds or not
heavy or anything like that
but they have four legs and they're able
to you know walk
without well i should say you walk
being able to reduce the risk of falling
when you have one of those walkers okay
and i produce zinc it did whatever i was
not getting your product but my own and
i i i don't taste things as much but
that made me stick
okay well zinc is also oftentimes used
we have a lozenge we have a little laws
that you know put in your mouth and it's
like about a half inch in diameter and a
quarter inch thick
and
it's one of those things where
zinc supports very specific reactions in
your immune system
and so with all uh
you wouldn't hurt you know to try cut
one of those in into a quarters you have
like a little little chunk of the zinc
and see what that does but don't forget
our colloidal silver a dropper full
under your tongue 30 minutes for each
meal um drop her full under your tongue
30 minutes for bedtime don't forget our
hand sanitizer and of course we have the
ancient legacy with all of these various
herbs and
oils and stuff like that you want to
kind of look at that
i use a lot of those oils from
from ancient legacy i put the eucalyptus
i put five or six drops of eucalyptus in
my hat and that kind of keeps the bugs
away that kind of thing and then of
course i use a hand sanitizer i use a
colloidal silver and i take all my
supplements
and i'm 83.
okay
so let's hear from you every couple of
weeks
because there's seniors who want to know
what's going on and want to hear how
you're doing so we look forward to
hearing from you okay
all right thank you jane we look forward
to you feeling so much better next week
and dr wallach we are at the end of the
program and we just want to thank you so
much for taking time out of your busy
schedule now we did have carey
um go ahead well yeah kerry put in a
comment that says
i love it when dr wallach is direct when
he told me what to do my
for my mom after her heart attack he
said that if she followed all the
medical device she'd be dead in five
years
i said dr wallach that's so blunt and he
said well i'm not here to sugarcoat it
i'm here to save her life and carrie
says she loves you so much for being so
blunt
and so we love you we love you back
carrie
we love you too rebecca well on behalf
of askdoc live thank you everybody for
being here with us this is a program
that you are able to share with others
and we do hope that you do
my co-host jonty mccollier who gets all
the electronic stuff running and keeps
it smooth and also our web designer
thank you so much jaunty thank you ruth
l and sanchez for keeping
everything flowing within the chat and
nasima omar as well and all of her
little helpful hints that she sends me
um everybody does
keeps me going
but askdoc life thank you so much
everybody for joining us we will see you
next time and again check out askdoc
askdoclive.com for all of our replays dr
rolex books and the youngevity products
bye for now